[Music]
hey sean yes sir howard doss how you
doing i'm good man little little hot it
is a little hot man we're getting into
the summer season we've uh we got back
from vegas we did fantastic time out
there speaking of hot vegas is like i
don't know surface of the sun hot right
now literally yes well it is here in
tulsa this weekend too it's pretty damn
hot yeah that's for sure but we've had
some great guests and we're glad to be
back in studio because we got some more
great guests here always uh i guess
today though
man
she probably had to go through one of
the and i'm gonna use this term right
now biggest media circuses that we have
ever seen absolutely i think in fact
that was probably the big that was the
first huge media circus that we went
through at least i don't want to say in
my lifetime i mean i think the way the
media has changed through the years this
was probably
the spot the the incident that i think
that they just became obsessed with and
i don't care if you're nine or you're 90
you you know about this case
correct so this was a this was a big
case that happened and we've never
gotten the perspective of the family
member and i can't i mean we just got
finished
going through all the ordeals of like
the amber herd and the johnny depp trial
and we've heard everybody else's opinion
but we haven't heard family members
opinion on what goes on with the crime
so that's what we're going to have on
today we've got a great guest in the
case that we're talking about is the
case of uh
the o.j simpson trial yes yes and today
we have uh kim goldman on there whose
brother was the one of the center
victims of that crime so she's going to
share what it was like to be involved in
that media circus and kind of tell us
what it
what she's done since then so welcome
today ms gomez good to have you
thank you i'm glad to be here
pleasure where are you coming to us from
where are you at
i'm in uh north of los angeles up in the
suburbs of l.a north of the valley okay
good california um i was actually just
out in l.a last week and uh i happened
to be there was perfect weather days i
was there for a few days
and uh don't laugh we went out there uh
uh somebody was going to the backstreet
boys concert at the hollywood bowl so
that's what we that's what we made the
trip out there for us so
i did not attend myself but we made sure
everybody that wanted to go got there
hey but you know what we like to do on
here hey and kim we didn't even ask you
what are you drinking today since we
like to have cocktails on cocktails and
cocktails
okay well i miss that so i might have to
ring my bell for my son or my future
husband in the house to get me a seven
and seven because that is usually what i
put in my cup but i was trying to be a
good girl today and have water but i i'm
gonna put my order in put it in yes
where the hell do you get a belt yeah we
need a bell here yeah we don't have a
belt when i when i turned um
40 my girlfriends gave me a drink bill
so i could just cling cling cling yeah
so have you ever heard of this
jason just got a new job
yeah jason is gonna be our drink bell
girl yes or yeah well we could hire
someone what are you drinking we're
going to drink some uh we're going to
drink some fantastic we're going to
drink what do you call these purple top
purple tops these are like bigfoots in
the bourbon world and what we're
drinking we're drinking a eight-year
will it bourbon uh 127.8
proof
uh time changes everything's the name of
it so every one of these barrels that
they do
they go ahead and they put uh whoever
picks the barrel gets to name it so
that's how this turned out so this is
some fine this is the finest of the corn
liquor out there and we'll toast to joan
on this one for sure yep because she's
she's been very good too very much so
cheers and old jessica out there
distillery yeah absolutely yeah
we need another bell
all right
i'll mail you one all right miss goldman
tell us what it was like to sit in that
courtroom while that was going on
um
you know it's it's it's so
it's hard to put into words it's just um
you know i ha i have to kind of remind
myself that you know it was 20 plus
years ago when i was a
a a younger
version of of my maturity my matured
self um it was incredibly overwhelming
and scary and confusing
you know i went to court every day and
i didn't miss
any day of testimony
and so i was balancing trying to be
um you know a pillar of strength for our
family and a representative while i was
also experiencing an immense grief i was
22 23 at the time um
and then just being dumped off into this
incredibly invasive
overwhelming experience um trying to
figure out who killed my brother and and
why it was getting such
you know national attention so it was
just a mixed bag
of high intensity
when did you hear the news that your
brother had been murdered
um on june 13th um i was living in san
francisco and i was a full-time student
at san francisco state and i was
working at wells fargo bank and i was on
shift that day and um
uh when i got home after 6 6 30
um
my boyfriend at the time we were living
together and he had he had already
received the call from my dad who told
him to be prepared
to support me when i got home and
my dad i called him and and uh because
he was asking for me to call and
uh
he had asked me if i had seen any ghosts
jeez i'm so sorry um he had asked me if
i'd seen any coverage um on the news uh
that day and i had no idea what he was
talking about um and he said you know do
you know nicole brown simpson what are
you do you know o.j simpson like why are
you asking me these ridiculous questions
and then he just blurted out that my my
they found my brother dead alongside
nicole
and these were 20 years ago this was
pre-iphone right we're on iphone 13 so
it's 13 years old this was what 28 years
ago right yeah yes it'll be yes 94. so
this was this was the days of the of the
brick cell phone that you know we almost
carried around in the little suitcases
this was
you know pager beeper days um so in my
apartment in san francisco we had one
landline um in our house um so this was
yeah pre pre-everything
for a couple new stations and that's it
for all of our listeners out there that
are younger than like 35 a landline is a
phone that was in your house that was
hooked to a cable and it had a cord and
depending on how cool your parent was
with the length of the cord right some
of them you had to stay within about
three feet of the wall right and now you
got like a good 25-footer you could
stretch from the kitchen to the living
room for a little privacy or the
bathroom or i i don't take phone calls
in the back of myself i didn't feel to
this day i don't well i wasn't using the
bathroom i was just kind of
it was a good i used to get yelled at
when i would stretch the cord out
because i wanted privacy and then my dad
would come in and our perfectly coiled
phone was all stretched out and and you
know because i would use my fingers and
twirl it and yeah oh same oh yeah yeah
you or a pin you'd run a pen through it
i'd do that a lot also i remember
actually i know we're kind of getting
off topic but when i was in high school
uh just because you know being a teenage
kid and i actually lived out in the bay
area myself and uh i worked just one of
the things i was saving for a car but i
also paid for my own phone line for my
bedroom so i had a phone line in my
bedroom well i got a quick story we're
going to go way off topic now where the
hell did you do that do you remember
your first phone number
that i don't i know my i know mine i put
it out there let's call it and find who
has it right now
three four eighteen eighteen is that
area code four i don't remember the area
code because i was well probably three
one two i was in chicago but i remember
six three four eighteen eighteen my very
first phone number five two one two five
seven eight well very nice yeah i
remember that no but so when i had mine
i'm just for all you younger listeners
i'm giving you an idea here
um
in my well i had a semester in school
where i like to skip school in high
school and i would show up every morning
i'd get up go to school and then we'd
all kind of skip out for the day and so
there's like the automated system where
the school would call you know hey your
son or daughter has missed one or more
periods today one of those type of deals
well i had a friend of mine that worked
in the office as like an office aide and
so we had changed it from the home phone
number to my bedroom phone so my parents
never knew i was missing school
and this went on for quite a while
during one semester and then my french
teacher had my mom's work number oh she
called my mom at work
and then that's when they found out the
number of days how much i'm missing
needless to say my phone line
disappeared but i enjoyed it while i had
it so
very nice
and i love the little french reference i
took french
that was unusual back then mm-hmm it was
well i i mean i i i knew i was going to
the law enforcement i should have taken
spanish obviously uh but you know i
thought it was like a romantic language
and it would help out with ladies and
gentlemen he's sensitive like that yeah
so you went through all of this i mean
it's hard for people to understand that
they don't have instantaneous
information right in their hand like
carrying around these small
little computers that we can find any
information out at any given time so you
get this call your dad tells you
um
i'm sure that you immediately go down to
be with your family
yeah i mean i you know i was living in
san francisco it's like a 45-50 minute
flight um i i was panicked i had no idea
what was going on we had very little
information at the time um it was not on
our newscast well i shouldn't say that
my brother's face was not on our
newscast yet um
in san francisco um
uh so i couldn't find anything
immediately um but i wasn't trying to
find it on the news i was just hurrying
up to pac um to get on our flight and we
raced um to oakland to get on the on the
flight out of oakland because it was
quicker and the first one available and
i just was a complete mess on the plane
i remember specifically the flight
attendant um
you know staring at me because i was
just i was sobbing and
um i just she was very worried about me
i remember that um and then we got off
the uh the air the airplane and you know
again that was pre-911 so you were
allowed to you know meet your your
family at the gate and smoke on the
plane
yeah um and so i i was
one of the last flights it wasn't very
full i remember getting off and i
remember seeing my dad at the end of the
the walkway um where you greet your
family and um i just remember
falling into his arms and just
completely collapsing
um because i just i never lost anybody
before and so
you know it was just completely jarring
to hear that it was my brother who was
the closest thing to me
uh you know outside of my dad and um
you know you just when you when you hear
that someone died you know usually you
think car accident or you know some kind
of natural
you know causes um but
we didn't know what had happened there
were rumors i should say rumors in that
first day that it was you know um that
he that they were gun shots i mean we
just had no information so we were very
much in the dark in those first um first
day or two
um and then
and then it caught on like wildfire
you know is is that pretty normal that
you kind of
what information you kind of have the
police have they kind of hold it back a
little bit and
yeah you know and just as we're talking
you know 28 years ago media compared to
now is definitely a little bit i mean
it's very different you know now police
departments themselves obviously have
social media and and you know
everybody's
not only demanding they expect
information from the police departments
on things that are happening and so
police departments you know using the
the word transparency they try to put
things out you know oftentimes hey we're
we're investigating a homicide over here
at this location you know even just
something as generic as that they try to
get it out
um but you know there are parts of an
investigation obviously that the police
if they don't want the public to know at
times and as tough as it is they don't
even want to share with the family
because it's they're hoping it doesn't
interfere with their investigation or a
suspect they're trying to track down you
know things like that so they have to
hold a lot of things you know close to
the chest
right because if they really if they
reveal all of the facts then everybody
has them and so the real killer wouldn't
they you want the real killer to be able
to have facts that otherwise other
people don't kind of think exactly yeah
exactly jeopardize the investigation
absolutely ideally you would like to be
able to identify who a suspect is after
you've spoken with when uh witnesses or
you've got some you know whether it's
forensic evidence
um you know ballistic evidence whatever
it may be you want to be able to sit
down with a suspect
and him basically not have had time
knowing what you know already to prepare
his defense to you face to face that's
why that first interview is so important
well from the time i think
i was just going to say you know i think
something that that stands out to me as
as being incredibly upsetting at the
time was that we you know when you watch
television um you know the the police
shows and law enforce you know legal
shows or whatever always there's a knock
at the door right and it's we're you
know sad to inform you that so-and-so we
didn't we didn't get that we had no
knock at the door we had no phone call
from anyone in the police department
it was the coroner's office that called
us um
to let us know and quite frankly it was
all day that they were trying to get a
hold of somebody in our family because
they didn't release my brother's name
until they made the first notification
which i appreciate
um and that actually i know this because
deborah tate is a friend of mine um that
that piece of uh
that notification system was because of
how sharon tate's murder was um shared
with the world before deborah tate's
family knew anyway off track um so
anyway we had the coroner's office call
and um talked to my stepmom my dad
wasn't even home and um she started to
relay the information to my stepmom who
was completely confused as to what was
happening and then my dad lo and behold
was walking through the door
as my stepmom patty was yelling fred
fred there's something wrong you need to
pick up the phone something happened to
ron and my dad picked up they were both
on the landlines um and claudia
radcliffe
the coroner she was the one that said um
you know ron had they found my brother
and um they found his id the driver's
license um
and that's how they knew it was him but
they we had random phone calls left on
our voicemail on our voice machine all
day long from people that were trying to
see if we were home
um and it was bizarre because we were
getting these weird calls and um people
that my brother knew and friends
uh that were wanting to know if he was
home
and then my stepmom was thinking why are
you calling my house ron doesn't live
here and so it was all a kind of a setup
to
just just strange it's little things and
and this i mean i i can't even not
exaggerating within 30 seconds of
the coroner and my dad hanging up my
brother's face was plastered all over
the news
ma'am i'm sorry i know that i i know
that you probably have talked to this
about this and i'm sure that even
talking to us now none of the pain has
really gone away i've known that i've
lost people when they were young and
there's just always a hole there that
you have so we really appreciate you
talking to us about it so from the time
that you got this information to the
time that let's call it the media circus
started or the trial started how long
was that
well those are two different things the
media circus started pretty immediately
when we were you know hounded by the the
journalists and press and phone calls
and you know from within a couple days
our street was lined with media trucks
and we were followed and
um it was everywhere um
uh so i would say the media circus was
pretty quick being that the
uh number one suspect was who he was um
but the trial you know it happened
fairly quickly i don't really know what
a standard time frame is for a trial but
it happened fairly quickly within a year
um and then it was just
you know they they called it the the um
you know camp oj
um at the at the
courthouse um and there was just you
know hoards of
platforms for media to sit um
and it was just
cameras everywhere microphones
everywhere you know um
journalists running around notepad i
mean it's just i mean you've seen the
images of it um but i don't think it
does it justice as to how how incredibly
invasive and overwhelming
um that that was it but it just it was
non-stop for a couple of years for sure
so you were 22 years old you're
basically being stalked by the media
did you have to quit your job at wells
fargo just go back i did i
i did i i went back um
i went back for a short period of time
and then realized i couldn't i couldn't
stay um it was too hard for me to be
away and court was happening you know
grand jury testimony you know grand jury
and
i wanted to be close to home and i just
i felt obviously very quickly very
isolated in san francisco and i made the
very difficult decision to
leave school i had you know half a
semester left i was you know
applying for my master's program and
uh i just
packed up and grabbed my cat in a
suitcase and and moved home and moved
into my my dead brother's room
yeah that's kind of tough
that's
yeah sorry
i appreciate that you know i just it
it's it's
you know my brother and i
very close and um you know we always
made a promise that would be we would be
there for each other no matter what and
so there was nowhere else for me to be
other than in court every day
um
being
you know a representative of him and
you know i
i wanted the killer i in very early on i
did not believe that that
who was acquitted was actually the
person that i felt committed the crime
um i was still kind of
reserving judgment until later on but i
wanted him and people to know that my
brother had a family my brother was very
quickly dismissed in the very early um
year of this and you know that was
upsetting and you know i wanted to make
sure that people knew that he had a
family that loved him and adored him and
you know that we're going to be by his
side until the very end
well and kim just like you said you know
the guy that obviously was acquitted and
you know
i mean
he became the focal point of this when
he was the suspect and it does it
dismisses the victims uh of the crime
and
you know because of that i know you
yourself you know like i said here you
know 25 plus years later you have uh you
know advocated basically to help the
victims of crime and i don't know if
necessary the word is rights but just
you've been part of organizations and
things like that
to kind of try to help people
work their their way through these type
of things and support the victims and
the victims families
yeah and i i
i feel i talk about it a lot i talk
about it on you know in the things i've
done publicly in books or whatever that
it's it's
it's a burden and it's a gift and
i have to be first and foremost being
able to put myself in a position that i
feel strong enough and vulnerable enough
um and committed enough to keep putting
myself out there because
it's
it's hard it's hard to and it's not
reliving because it's it's always with
me it's just you know sometimes i bring
it more into the focus and sometimes i
let it sit sit back and rest a little
bit so when i choose to be outspoken
about victims issues and survivor issues
and you know the impact of media or law
enforcement you know i just have to kind
of bring it back up and be like okay
today's the day i got to psych myself
out there's a bigger message here a
bigger purpose and then i need to figure
out a way to self-care and
go back to taking care of myself and my
son and my family and um
but i i can't not do it um because there
is such a tremendous need and
you know because our family's case was
so high profile i feel
um an intense need to just keep talking
about things because there's a platform
and not every family gets that and
that's horrible and so
um our our case our loss isn't any
greater than anybody else's because it
was on television but if we have the
platform it's an opportunity for us to
try to bring things to the light that
don't often get to be there
yeah for sure and and you know i i guess
what's the hardest thing about that and
i mean obviously you and i don't know
one another but i was a police officer
for 25 years and just retired and you
know been a part of numerous uh you know
homicide cases and testifying and things
like that and there's people who i have
100 percent felt were guilty of you know
the accused crime and were found not
guilty um and obviously with this one
you know with your brother this thing
being on the platform it was what's so
difficult and for any of the listeners
whether you think you know oj did it or
not
again it goes back to taken away from
the victims you know uh
you know your brother and nicole
because it was there were people that
were just celebrating cheering the
streets that he was not guilty but if
he's not you know if he's in fact not
the person that did it not saying he's
not guilty if he's in fact not the
person that did it you still have two
victims that there's no justice for and
that just
got completely lost
in the we keep using the word the media
circuit just got lost in the media
circus and the and the people that you
know just uh were enthralled with it
you know but but thank you for saying
that um to that point though when we
talk about
the difference between media then versus
now there's a whole new generation of
viewers and listeners um that
know about the case and study the case
and have opinions now about the case who
also now have access
to
me and our family and other victims you
know um that
have no
tact necessarily when sharing their
100 no 100 so
it is now to this point like okay well
you can you can think that he didn't do
it but my brother was still stabbed to
death and i'm still without a family
member so you can think he didn't do it
but why do you hate me so much like why
i get tons of hate mail
and why i i still have a loss just
because i believe someone did it that
you don't doesn't take away from the
loss and what my brother nicole endured
that that night and that's the part that
is really hard for me to reconcile um
it's it's sort of this
you know
people are my feeling is people are
desensitized a little bit because we
have so much crime and trauma that it is
really hard to remind yourself that
there is a person attached to the story
and um you know lives are lost and
there's grief well yeah and kind of just
following up on that thought i mean
nowadays you know when you've got an
open case
um where somebody hasn't been charged
and just like you're referring to these
you know
couch sleuths or whatever it is the
people you know whether they think
they're doing
good by their their stuff but they come
up with a lot of wild conspiracy
theories and they really do and it's
shared on you know reddit or internet or
their youtube channels or whatever it is
and so
it i'm telling you as a police officer
it oftentimes can interfere with the
case you know with what's really going
on or you know where the case is really
going because these people at home who
have never interviewed a real person in
their life
uh you know they're talking shit
literally that's it they spur things off
i mean we see it in all you know i mean
guys you see it in politics you see it
in people criticizing law enforcement
and so forth but yeah and then you end
up chasing leads
and you end up chasing leads that may or
may not pan out to anything as opposed
to the ones that are actually legitimate
because you enter in a situation that
you can't leave any stone unturned
so if you have all of these people out
there throwing shit against the wall you
have to see what sticks and what doesn't
but you have to
handle every piece of shit and so
you know i i worry about that i mean you
know we haven't talked about it much but
yet but with my podcast that's part of
why i wanted to do it is to really kind
of
share with people the the ins and outs
of this the stuff that they don't really
understand um the impact of some of
those you know web sleuths and
conspiracy theories and all that stuff
that really can kind of derail uh you
know the legal and the in uh the
investigative process
one of the things that we like to do on
this podcast is we like to humanize
everybody right we like to
everybody's got a story to tell
the big thing that i see with you is 22
years old i've got a couple of daughters
he's got a daughter they were about your
age when this happened so i immediately
empathize with that the big thing that
i'm seeing from you that i'm curious
about is
how did you develop stress resilience
because
you you
you are under a tremendous amount of
stress and it sounds like you're still
under stress from this thing that
happened
dang near three decades ago
you know
i thank you for asking that um that
doesn't usually get discussed um i
didn't handle it very well in the
beginning um
i i remember vividly the day that my dad
pinned me down and forced me to take a
valium because i was completely out of
my mind and i wasn't sleeping and i was
a hot mess
i lost i'm already a fairly petite
person and i lost a tremendous amount of
weight and it wasn't because i wasn't
eating i just couldn't couldn't keep
anything on i wasn't sleeping um my dad
and i both have not slept well since
that day it's just
body doesn't let me relax completely um
but i i turned to uh i had a wonderful
therapist early on um but support groups
uh were not entirely
available at the time um because our
case was so public that there was no
place i could go to have some anonymity
and privacy and so i didn't feel safe
uh so i retreated i am isolated uh
surrounded myself with just a hand a
handful of people um that i trusted and
it was a little bit later once all the
trials ended that i really started to
kind of embrace my healing and my
morning a little bit
and that just included therapy and
journaling and writing um i come from a
life of uh
psychology and so i used some of the
skills i learned in therapy growing up
but i was a psych major at the time so
those things came in handy and then i to
be honest with you i separated myself a
little bit so that i could get my
footing back um and then really tried to
realign myself with what was important
to me and then
i struggle every day every day it's a
conscious effort to take a deep breath
to put myself first to get some sunshine
on my face to
you know take a deep breath um to
exercise whatever it is but every day i
have to choose to to
stay balanced in some and then i give
myself permission to just fall apart
also
and let that be part of the process
well the media really doesn't have many
boundaries i mean they'll get up in your
business everybody else will get up in
your business like you said it
the way that i kind of equate what you
went through is it's like watching an
mma fight you know everybody's
interested everybody wants to watch the
fight i want to see i want to see him
get hit in swings and i'll see him break
down and all that stuff but they're not
the people actually in there taking the
punches so it's really easy to be a
spectator on this why do you think
people
go ahead sorry
why do you think people find this so
goddamn fascinating
i
i hate to say because i think of who he
was
is the killer um i think i did not
understand him
to be a celebrity type i wasn't into
football then i you know i wasn't living
in los angeles i grew up in chicago so i
had no
no idea who he was his you know football
and fame wise um
and i i don't know if it was because it
was the first time it was actually a
case like that was televised i mean
before that i think the first case was
probably the menendez brothers um oh
yeah
but that really didn't anywhere come
close to where our case did um
so i don't know i don't know if it was a
beautiful blonde woman and you know
and a handsome brother like i i mean i
don't i don't know i mean i'm still
completely this is not just you know us
either this was
you know international we were getting
mail from people in the netherlands and
you know south africa europe italy i
mean
so far-reaching um and i don't i don't
know and it still is that is that way um
i don't i don't know i'm fascinated by
it well two things first mail is a thing
that used to come in a box that we would
get from people
and it would come to you that's one the
other thing is your brother was
beautiful i sit next to a very ugly man
every day and your brother was much
better looking than this guy
thank you thank you you know it's funny
you say that about mail we used to get
mail sent to our house goldman family
agora california that's it no no
because there was no ability to search
the internet to know what zip codes were
so it just got put in the mail and i
don't know how in the heck it came to us
um i had no idea but i vividly remember
mail just that's it there was no other
identifying so how much mail did you get
yes
oh my gosh buckets and buckets of mail
and we read through every single piece
really
i've recently i i remember vividly
um when the civil case started uh we got
we were opening mail we had it we
finally at that point had a p.o box um
there was a piece of mail that came and
it was from a um it was from a young i
don't know nine ten-year-old um who had
so sweet they put a dollar in the
in in the in the envelope with a letter
and they said i'm supporting you and and
we're behind your family here hope this
helps
and it just
you know in the face of so much hate
that we had received it was stuff like
that that really just reminded us that
we were doing the right thing that you
know we had truth on our side and and
that people were connecting with our our
our focus and that they loved my brother
um in a way that i was just really
fortunate to be able to share yeah you
know if anybody takes the time to write
a letter and and i hope the majority of
it was supportive um you know that was
coming to you but you know even part of
the live pd show um fan mail became a
thing and it was
i don't want to say it was
odd to me but it definitely was
different um you know because i'm just
like man a regular dude that's a cop and
you know my police department almost
every day is getting fan mail that's
showing up there at the department um
that they're having to deliver out to my
division but all of it was fantastic and
it i mean some of the things that were
sent were interested interesting i had
i had one i mean yeah you want to tell
us well no no there's nothing like that
but i i mean i had a woman that made
homemade toothpaste that wanted to say
toothpaste i don't know what was her
name martha stewart i don't know but
just when you talk i mean literally
homemade toothpaste uh did you use it i
did not um you know
nothing against
somebody if i knew making it you know i
just don't know what was in it but just
going back to even the one dollar it
actually
there was somebody who sent i want to
say it was like three or four hundred
dollars to me like literally three or
four hundred bucks and it was just
they're like hey just wanna let you know
we still support police and i put it to
a non-profit um you know it wasn't
something i kept myself but it just
you're talking about a kid there are
people out there even in these you know
horrific thing like your family was
going through um you know the
for me the police profession kind of
just getting you know
kicked while it's down type of thing
there are people out there that still
support they just don't get that media
uh love i guess is the word for media
attention
yeah
yeah and i think i think it's really
helpful you know we we are in a a time
period now where you know the hatred is
what's amplified and so yes when there
are times that we can highlight the
alternative because it's really easy i
mean and i'm sure you experience this um
i only remember that you know it's
really easy to remember the negative
stuff and so i have to consciously you
know remind myself of all the positives
so we still have the the letters that's
in my dad's garage in arizona um but not
all of them but a majority of them um
because it's really helpful to remind
yourself that there's goodness out there
and when you know i would imagine in
your your line of work sean that you saw
so much
despair and and you know
ugh ugliness you know that you have to
have those moments where you can take uh
you know to be gracious and and have
some gratitude about the impact that you
were having yeah absolutely let me ask
you this uh
you know you talked about when the
notification came it came from the the
coroner's office and i'm just
backtracking a little bit here what was
it like for your family
you know
working with the
lapd you know the detectives or even the
district attorney's office back then you
know through not just the initial
investigation but up through the trial
and post i mean you know whether it's
good or bad
yeah very early on there was i i don't
have very vivid memories of having
conversations um
uh
and that isn't to say they didn't happen
i just don't have very vivid ones they
were if they were few and far between um
i remember meeting marcia clark the
first time um i remember having a call
with tom lange and phil vanetta who were
the lead detectives
um but they were just you know
giving us you know brief overview of
what to expect um and and what to
prepare for but again we weren't given
any pr we weren't privy to any
information
um i really liked marcia clarke when i
first met her she was incredible and i
felt very lucky uh chris darden who uh
became the prosecutor um he wasn't the
original one it was bill hodgman um who
ended up having a heart attack and had
to pull himself off second chair um
but
uh
chris was a little standoffish in the
beginning and then as the trial
progressed those roles switched a little
bit and i became much closer with chris
he and i are very good friends to this
day marsha became a little bit um
more standoffish she had a lot going on
if people remember she was being you
know dragged through the mud as well
as the trial progressed i got super
close with everybody in the district
attorney's office the investigators the
lapd um i i felt like they were the only
people fighting for my brother nicole so
i took
i really i supported i was outspoken i
hated when people were negative and made
disparaging comments to this day i i'm
almost unwilling to see where there were
mistakes made
um i cop to that because
i don't
i don't want to take away from what they
were up against i don't want to take
away from um who the killer was and and
the scrutiny that they were under
yes i'm sure mistakes were made but none
of them
were grave enough that it was going to
change the outcome i mean if they had a
videotape of the killer doing it
something would have come out that it
was you know edited it wasn't him it you
know and so
i just feel like they were the people
that fought the hardest for my brother
nicole and i am forever indebted um to
them and they all really suffered
greatly um throughout that case and
after so
um the people are close to my heart i'm
sure they got some hate mail too yeah i
can only imagine and i just pulled it up
right here uh
i mean just in 1994 in la county which
is who would have prosecuted the case
you know keep in mind this is back in
the
i mean literally the height of gang
violence that was going on and uh you
know the west coast east coast things
like that i mean that was when it's at
its highest point in l.a county that
year 1669
homicides so a lot of people that's a
lot so you know this case obviously i
said i don't want to say rose to the top
but definitely got the most attention so
just the prosecutors out of that office
and the number of cases they're working
to begin with is overwhelming and then
you have one of this magnitude that the
media attention and stuff like that well
and it was also
it was also on the heels of the rodney
king um police beating story um in los
angeles and
um
and i know this is a very small fact but
our case my brother's murder happened in
santa monica which is a different
jurisdiction than where the case was
tried in los angeles and so that was a
big point of contention back then
because we didn't understand why it was
being moved
to downtown l.a which
changed the jury pool and so
um
lots of thoughts about that but it did
change the jury pool um
and the reason gil garcetti who was the
district attorney at the time the reason
he said he did it was because you know
the downtown office could withstand all
the media and i'm thinking
why is that your priority like that why
isn't the case just in the jurisdiction
that the that the murder happened and so
in hindsight i see now why that may have
hurt us but at the time i thought okay i
didn't
oh this building is bigger i didn't
think anything of it but there was a lot
of um uh
issues around that decision as well
sure yeah lawyers think a lot different
hey sean have you noticed i've had more
energy during this podcast you have
today you sleep better last night no no
no no i didn't i have uh we got we've
got some good stuff that we're having
i've been drinking this magic mind you
have it in the morning with your
caffeine i don't drink coffee because
you're a you're a tea drinker i am i'll
drink some tea in the morning i might as
well be british the way i like the tea i
do like i don't put milk in it but i
like a good tea but this uh this stuff's
helping me man it's making me more
focused it's given me more energy
and uh it's making me a little bit
happier no it is i yeah you know they
the the folks out of magic of mine sent
that out to us earlier this week and
i've had it the last couple days you
know i'm not was it matcha is that this
is
matcha i'm not a matcha tea guy
generally i am a coffee guy in the
morning that's it i'm not one of these
all day guys i rarely drink an energy
drink but i've been giving this a try
and uh it first of all it actually
tastes good i was very surprised it's
like a natural
thing it is green it is green but uh i
think it's fantastic man tastes great
well i was with you the first time i had
it i was like this it's two ounces i'll
see what it yeah it's good came down i
think it's the honey it's got a little
bit of sugar i've been on this new diet
too so it's really helpful it's 15
calories and this stuff is a pep in your
step and where can people find magic
mind oh they can get it online they can
if you go to magicmind.com uh you sign
up for the subscription kim i hope
you're taking notes here you see that
from i am i actually that's what i'm
doing on my computer yeah yeah
absolutely yeah good good answer uh you
know you can get uh with a subscription
like 40 off and i think there's a 20 off
uh like one time deal use this the code
sticks
that's you 20 620 sticks
20. yeah so try that shot man honestly
it's good it is a shot it's two ounces
yeah it's a little shot so it's kind of
take it one in the morning let it
replace your all that caffeine you might
get from coffee and help yourself out
kim it may help with some stress
resilience too it is
literally it says relax it says on right
here gives you energy second life
excellent health helps you relax
aptogens is so keeps you focused
and makes you happy what more could you
ask for
okay
so these interviews fly i mean they
absolutely fly but we we really need to
get into
what you're doing these days yeah
what am i doing these days um i am um i
am a parent to a first-year college
student you just came home from college
so you know what venmo is right i do yes
oh my gosh yeah or cash app
cash up yes ridiculous um so i'm raising
my son i'm i'm newly engaged and i
am
thank you
yeah
and uh he gave you a ring and a bell
he did right yeah he's actually coming i
just reminded him um so
i but we have to toast um
and i am launching a podcast um aptly
called media circus which we've been
talking about a little bit here yeah
imagine that um i wrote a book a handful
of years ago with the same name um and i
i interviewed families and survivors
from victims and survivors from
high-profile cases uh dating back to the
early 1960s and um wanted to take people
kind of behind the scenes where where
journalists and cameras leave off and
really tell people
what goes on when the cameras go away
and how people deal with um their trauma
and their grief and their resiliency and
and kind of let people into where the
the media got it right got it wrong um
and to hopefully sensitize people to
what the stories are that they're
listening to and to remind that there's
humans attached to it and so my podcast
is very similar to that except it's like
this although we're not doing audit
video but um
so i've i've already been talking with
um families uh george floyd's family's
gonna be uh coming up in a week or two
ago uh and fred guttenberg um uh his
daughter jamie was killed in parkland
judy shepard uh her son matthew shepard
was one of the
worst hate crimes of our time um
kelsey german her sister liberty german
was killed it's an unsolved case right
now is known as the snapchat murders
um
one of the victims of jeffrey epstein um
so we've got a lot of really great
stories and people that are coming to
just share their insight
we're releasing june 12th and then our
first episode's dropping on july 11th
let me ask you this i'm really excited
yeah yeah let me ask you i'm going to
ask you of a favor it's obviously your
podcast you do whatever you want
but i
i am requesting uh maybe at some point
read out reach out to the family of a
police officer you know because it is
you know there's officers obviously
a police officer gets killed in the line
of duty and there's a small blurb about
it but a police officer kills somebody
even totally justified it's a big
national story often times yeah and the
police officers families have to go
through those things you know we had an
officer that was shot and killed here
two years ago
you know here in tulsa just a horrible
situation and you know just the family
she had two little boys and stuff like
that and i'm just i'm not saying
particularly her just a story about a
police officer and what their family
goes through uh you know because it does
it gets forgotten very quickly because
yeah a lot of people out there just
think oh it's a police officer's job
he's that's okay it's supposed to happen
or it does happen it's just part of it
now i'm really glad you
i'm i just just to that point really
quickly i really i a part of it's on my
list we actually have someone um one of
the capital police from the insurrection
that was important to me too um but the
point is is i think it's interesting to
to kind of redefine what a victim and
survivor is and it isn't just what the
media tells us it is and so the hope of
the
show is to really kind of broaden
people's minds um and just to be more
compassionate and sensitive that it
doesn't always look the way we think it
does so
i'm glad that you're bringing that up
i'm super super pro you know law
enforcement so it's always important to
me to make sure that i share that side
of story so thank you
well there's two things that i i've got
one of them i think the thing that you
said right then was you looking to
sensitize people and we've got all these
people who have been desensitized you
know all the shit comes at us so fast
you know it's it's like snow on a
windshield you just you can't see all of
it you know it's just like it gets lost
in there so yeah like big big kudos for
sensitizing people of course but the
other thing is is that i want to get
your opinion what what do you think of
this
recent media circus that we had that
was with uh mr depp mrs hurt
oh you know
i really struggled um
i really struggled because i am
obviously super sensitive to issues
around domestic violence
um and watching what went on between the
two of them was heartbreaking um you
know watching two people in such a toxic
relationship um and be so viscerally
angry and violent towards each other
whether it's just psychological
emotional or physical um it was really
hard um and i'm i'm glad that we were
having that conversation but my gosh the
way that that went down and the people
against amber against team johnny team
amber like how did we get to this place
that we're starting to question
whether or not someone's experience was
that bad or whether or not it ruined
your career i mean these are two people
that that destroyed each other and i
just
i'm glad we're having the conversation i
wish it was in a healthier way that it
wasn't so exploitive
because i think it can set um domestic
violence victims back whether they're
men
victims or women um i think that this is
one of those things that says well why
am i going to bother to share my story
because this is what i'm gonna get um so
um i wish we just had healthier dialogue
around it is what i would i would say to
that
cooler heads yeah very much so well just
my advice to that is
get out of the relationship you know
what i mean if you've got the problems
like you said the problems that went on
there for years and years and again
whether she was a victim of domestic
violence or he was the victim of
domestic violence or both of them
whatever
whether it's counseling or just get the
hell away from one another you guys you
know there's other people you can be
with out there because that's just
horrible this is true i i want to say i
know i know we probably have to go soon
but shawn i just i want to say something
having all the work that i've done with
victims and survivors especially with
domestic violence um they always say
it's not that hard right whether it's a
male or woman but obviously
predominantly it's women that are in
these situations
they're being controlled their money's
being controlled they're being
threatened with their safety of their
children their family their livelihood
right and it's not that easy to just get
out
but i will say if we had a better
support system as a country if we were
more compassionate as a society if we
were more encouraging and and more of a
safety valve for people i think it might
lend itself to being a wee bit easier
but i don't think we truly understand
how hard um you know folks are
manipulated in those situations that it
just isn't it just isn't that easy
um especially when you got a gun to your
head you know
like yeah yeah so wait you hit the road
i think the word right there is
manipulation right right on there that's
that's it that's the big problem in a
lot of these
well kim goldman thank you so much for
your time on here it's been a pleasure
congratulations on your engagement so by
the way san francisco was that the dons
am i right was that the this or is that
uh san francisco state was that the the
san francisco state dons wasn't that
their mascot or what was that
there's one of them up there that's the
dons
no
that's florida i don't remember what i
was it was it was green i remember that
yeah
congratulations i know you guys got a
shawn your show with dan abrams got
picked up um
so i was i was happy to hear that um i'm
proud of you guys um so i know it
changed networks and all that and but
i'm happy to see you're back on the air
we yeah we are very very excited so and
i kind of joke about so is my bank
account
well it was a pleasure having you cheers
cheers thank you yeah my drink i don't
know what happened i'll drink to water
and cheers you another thing
fire them marry them but fire them
thank you yeah okay all right thanks
again take care bye
[Music]